les deux chacun mettent les plus rapides
aux échecs tu vois ces cases là tu as
des cases les plus vulnérables aux
échecs je veux faire échec et mat il
faudra que tu arrives à exploiter cette
faiblesse de l'adversaire la façon la
plus rapide de le faire et celle-ci si
les blancs bougent ces pions là peu
importe dans quel ordre les Noirs auront
seulement à bouger le pion du roi et
ramener la dame en H4 et bam ça serait
chacun les Noirs auront réussi à faire
chaque match en seulement debout le
premier était un peu aidé mais le
deuxième est beaucoup plus facile à
replacer pour le faire c'est très simple
on bouge le pion du roi on sort le fou
on C4 la dame en L5 les deux pièces qui
attaquent simultanément la faiblesse en
F7 dont on parlait tout à l'heure si le
nom ne dépendent pas ce pion F7 tu as un
point F7 et bam c'est maths alors faites
attention à ce type d'idée défendez bien
votre pion F2 ou F7 et bonne chance en
pleine partie pour mater rapidement vos
adversaires sur la case F7 ou F2